há quem diga que eu sou designer
inventor engenheiro mas a idéia começa
sempre com um esboço dos vôos foi da
pressa não guardanapo na para trás do
bloco de esquerda e desapareça
neste caso trata-se de uma base para um
tacho atravessa também certo passou a
ser feita diariamente enquanto as
crianças dos países a pôr à mesa
a idéia não é genial mas o que importa
aqui não ainda em si mas consigo não pôr
em prática enquanto tenta concretizar as
minhas ideias para um sempre com o mesmo
problema
eu tenho que criar um design técnico
explica e daí detalhe mas desenvolver um
produto sozinho é difícil e dolorosa foi
precisamente as caras e complicadas
partindo do princípio que têm acesso a
essas ferramentas a um software o
computador
os materiais ea oficina terá ainda de
pagar cinco mil e quinhentos euros e
criar uma patente e propriedade
intelectual em portugal não falar na
europa e no resto do mundo
cinco mil e quinhentos euros por uma
idéia é ter algum retorno neste
investimento teria então que o essencial
é pena é não me batendo uma empresa com
os mais de produzir e ganhei apenas um
pequeno volte proporcional essas vendas
eis o problema como inventor eu sou
forçado a abdicar da minha ideia e já
não sou eu quem faz chegar ao consumidor
eu queria também formar uma empresa como
fez por exemplo o arquiteto henrique
albino quando os anos 60 the civil criar
mobília design contemporâneo ms já no
alentejo a forma como se chamava a
empresa foi pioneira em tecnologias
únicas do protótipo passar em
transformação e reciclagem do zinho
criaram peças emblemáticas de ovar o
design português como por exemplo o
painel fotógrafos que assistiu à sala
vip do aeroporto de lisboa
mas mesmo assim fica cada vez mais fácil
mais difícil dizer
faça a mão de obra barata nos
continentes
eu sou da geração made in china chico
viável plástico criado em moldes aos
milhões é que a globalização hábito nos
cada vez a ficar mais consumidores e
dependendo de outros para construir um
mundo à nossa volta mas o mundo está a
mudar
tem se falado muito da cultura marca ou
do movimento marca um evento michael
usar criarem público é o prazer do
fabrico do artesanato e do restauro como
modo de expressão social que está a
acontecer a gente como nós de todas as
profissões estão a começar a criar e
partilhar o que queriam
em 2005 esta revista veja também trouxe
um símbolo desta comunidade que cria
pelo prazer de criar e inclui por
exemplo em seus sonhos para quem quiser
aprender a construir uma impressora 3d
ou fazer tricô ou seja lá o que for à
vista além do sucesso desta vez do
google que era preciso transformar o
conceito do diário o faça você mesmo
isso implica criar sozinho quase um ano
pois ou só um ano depois hoje da revista
sair em abril a primeira marca fé na
califórnia onde centenas de pessoas
famílias e grupos amadores vieram
mostrar suas criações
há dezenas de milhares de visitas e é
café também chegou a portugal este ano
atraiu mais de 15 mil visitas todo o
país mostra que existe uma comunidade
forte e entrosado
lá no caminho do conhecimento estavam
aposentados grupos universitários como
por exemplo oficinas as energias da
universidade de lisboa eo seu painel
solar que segue uma fonte de luz estavam
grupos de artesãos com a melhora
criativa que se sair no nó ciclagem
atualização dos profissionais tenham um
espaço de convívio
viu e desenvolvimento de competências
estavam lá também projetos open source
desenvolvidas em espaços colaborativos
como fábio lisboa
este projeto foi uma parceria entre o
fábio e com a associação dos artesãos da
região de lisboa e resultou num tear que
foi conseguido por ser muito barata de
fabricar em qualquer mac os pés e muito
fácil montar foi um sucesso tão grande
chama imensa jantava participar em
workshops de montagem mas o que o
professor ou professora é uma atitude de
partilha que acelera o desenvolvimento
de um produto e melhora a sua qualidade
a verdade é que a melhor maneira de
aprender e copiar o trabalho dos outros
é sério porque ao copiar nós ganhamos
confiança e tornam o nosso adaptando o
nosso contexto
hoje em dia todos nós usamos software
desenvolvido desta maneira como o
android
o mozilla firefox até o novo windows 10
é um passo importantíssimo na criação de
competências e de autodidatas que defina
indústria tecnológica a proteção reunida
da propriedade intelectual sob protesto
da inovação
voltemos a um esboço no guardanapo
ao partilhar esta ideia eu divulga torna
pública o que eu ganho com isso e
rapidamente recebeu ibaka uma comunidade
interessada como essa que em movimento
um censo participativo que pode
transformar um projeto um produto com o
apoio e divulgação
a família não basta a divulgação é um
produto tem que se manifestar no mundo
real e para isso preciso de acesso a
ferramentas estão tradicionalmente
fechadas em espaços industriais onde o
público não pode entrar
desde a abertura do primeiro fábio não é
marketing
isto é saber que este laboratório até
quem já sabe
a essa altura que perceberam 546 pelo
mundo fora sem deus em portugal estão
equipados com os principais ferramentas
para fazer tudo e mais alguma coisa
15 46 até aparece no alto mas não se
compara o número de máquinas peças
hackers psc na veste lábios mccafé e por
aí fora que estudarão possíveis com o
conhecimento e as ferramentas foram
desenvolvidas sem segredo industrial
como por exemplo esta máquina de corte
de custo um décimo de sua equivalente a
estrela e pode ser montado em qualquer
meio que os pés uma das 10 às forças
nestas ferramentas digitais é que a
complexidade do produto que fabricam não
aumenta o custo de produção e isto é uma
impressora 3d tem tanta facilidade em
primeiro um cubo como uma vênus do meu
eo mesmo se aplica ao número de
imunizados tão fácil fazer uma ou sangue
numa manhã de quinta feira eu esquiei
alpendre do fábio lisboa com intenções
de fazer um protótipo chamado do rosário
um professor do liceu que passa o seu
tempo livre no sábado a criar sabão
artesanal inspirava duas voz tradicional
português está num pedaço de sabão
peixeirada também precisam ser amêndoa
amarga mas com minha opinião e os outros
lá por exemplo eu fui quanto a continuar
as suas crenças
eu percebo então em acabado colaborar no
projecto de um dos médicos residentes
o inventor solitário negou se a internet
tornou se um empreendedor global por
mais pequeno e regional que seja o seu
produto tem uma equipa do
desenvolvimento enorme tem financiamento
gratuitamente atribuído através do
próprio flamengo e tem acesso ao mercado
global através do e commerce ou das
vendas online também tem a faculdade
adaptar o seu produto e captar mercado
de nicho que não estão ao alcance dos
grandes produtores
e com isso não quer dizer que os
empreendedores são os alimentos máquinas
e que os médicos são necessariamente
empreendedores mas os meus pés estão
encontrar essa intuição ecossistema de
inovação entre os centros de
conhecimento como as universidades e os
centros de empreendedorismo estão a
criar uma ponto que acelerar a
transformação do conhecimento em
soluções desligar nós como é que não é a
vontade de criar uma grande empresa é
vontade nos tornarmos independentes
delas e com o acesso a estes recursos
sociais e tecnológicos e acesso ao
mercado global estamos finalmente o
mesmo objetivo um bom sinal visto o
crescimento espetacular de sites como s
eo amazonas em médici foco nos produtos
feitos à mão e eu não podia deixar de
estar a ser linhas portuguesas e se
quisermos outra cor
basta ouvir esta marca de cascais
tamanho meu passou que foi desenvolvido
com a ajuda de uma comunidade ajudou a
escolher o burel esta holanda serra da
estrela foi participada no tablado com a
ajuda de outros médicos que me ensinaram
usar a máquina que corta luz a uma
criança consegue captar cada um destes
elefantes telex em 25 segundos e
permitiu fazer até 100 mil unidades sem
única mesmo nem sem uma única vez
repetir a mesma combinação de cores
também estrutura agora se avançar para
marcar falta consciência que as
primeiras vendas vão gerar vão gerar
mais fibra óptica que vai contribuir com
uma segunda versão do produto sem que
isso aumente uma construção
isto não teria sido possível sem o
movimento vai querer que vai agregar
organizados que puseram as ferramentas
digitais de fábrica ao meu alcance mas
que infelizmente não estavam ao alcance
da forma como foi nos anos 80
de que forma o show da vila não se joana
perdeu 650 habitantes quase não tava seu
popozão antiga casa do dono foi do avaí
transformada em museu onde agora estão
os artefactos dos dias prósperos mostram
competência de transição portuguesa
será que nesta nova era
mas essa informação com estas novas
ferramentas da fábrica à mão
não se pode voltar mas jana e outras
zonas rurais portuguesas tão perigoso
declínio econômico e cultural e voltar a
produzir com novos modelos produtivos e
inclusão social
o carro um salto e achar alguém neta do
fundador da forma que estou a fazer isso
mesmo a deus que o projeto pretende
criar um espaço de encontro entre dois
mundos urbano tecnológico e rural é
artesanal é um em uma oficina e um
espaço de convívio aberto ao público
permitindo a make os visitantes artesãos
entrarem e documentar em processos que
estão em vias de esquecimento e também
trazer ferramentas novas e deixou de
produzir começaram com uma casa pequena
numa rua inclinada com três assoalhadas
pequeninas tentaram salvar as quase
todas as paredes interiores e
desenvolvemos um plano pra cozinha
construída uma menina que se virado
dormitório tanto para os dons mas como
exames médicos e outras visitas poderão
também vir de outras vilas e cidades
trocar experiências e conhecimento
a oficina europeus no jardim com telhas
de uma ruína local suportadas proposta
da atrocidade que encontrou villa nova
na horizontal
o hoteleiro o canalizador que o artista
da vila ajudaram a construir o espaço e
sabem que vão poder usufruir deu porque
quis entrar a atividade do bonfim cujas
ferramentas digitais vão fazer lambança
do trovão da transição
já na vila já é marca há muito tempo
gabriel